i haven't really thought about that it's
just more so the fact that being blessed
to be back here in this position i mean
last year unfortunately it ended soon
for me
so being back here i like to thank god
and you know i like to say he doesn't
make no mistakes and it's not by
accident
brandon cooks drafted the first round by
the saints traded to the patriots for a
first-rounder traded to the rams for a
first rounder
no no i i was gonna make a point about
brandon cooks i did not write about this
okay but when i was in the car on
saturday morning with sean mcvay you
know riding with him to work i brought
up this point i said brandon cooks is 25
years old every year he has 1200 yards
receiving and he's been traded twice
why
and he made a great point he goes listen
a lot of times when you're putting a
roster together
you have to decide how much money you
are going to devote to certain positions
right and over the years
we have in my opinion
i'm okay with devoting a certain amount
of money to the receiver position
because i have i have needs at the
receiver position basically that i
really can identify and he goes and he
wouldn't didn't he wasn't specific and
he said and new england's just different
yeah and his point is new england can
get by with chris hogan making whatever
he makes three million yeah right
amendola left you know you can talk to
him about amendola about this mike
amendola left because he was never going
to make any money in new england
bill believes that and he's shown it
time and again
that he can get chris hogan amendola
welker you know edelman he can get those
kind of receivers to play these roles
and if they want too much money he's
going to go find another one right
there's probably four of them in the
draft this year where he says i'll go
get john doe from
from west virginia or whatever in the
sixth round and nobody likes them
because his height weight speed
measurables aren't exactly where they
are or he didn't time perfectly in the
40. but bill's gonna go i've seen enough
film to know he's fast and he beats this
guy and he's a good rat runner and he
his brain can understand the all the
intricacies of the offense to where
that's where they're brilliant because
they get those type of guys just yes
they're not overly physically gifted but
they're mentally capable of handling a
tremendous workload like we've talked
about a lot of times one of the great
strengths of the patriots offense is
brady's inventory of plays it's 18 years
of a rolodex of plays and everybody on
the team's got to keep up with tom so
you better get some receivers who can
handle that mental workload and when
things change on the fly as the ball
snap they better be able to react or tom
will get your buddy i keep i keep
waiting for the moment it might happen
this offseason or next offseason we're
going to read in a little agate type in
the newspaper for those of us who still
get newspapers new england dash
sign freeagent
ryan switzer yeah right you know i mean
because it's going to happen
he's that guy and and i look at the game
right now and and i keep saying oh my
god belichick should never traded
brandon cooks and you know probably he
would love to have brandon cooks in this
game but
at 1 8 the price he'll figure out how to
win games without him brandon cooks took
the wicked blow to the head from malcolm
jenkins in super bowl 52 so we didn't
see much of them then the patriots are
going to see plenty of him now how does
belichick take that knowledge of brandon
cooks and use it against him and slow
him down you've got cooks on one side
woods on the other side we talked
yesterday that you can't if you focus on
taking one away the other one's going to
beat you what do you do with those two
i mean i still think new england's gonna
play man-to-man cooks i may not cook
stefan gilmore jc jackson they're
phenomenal jc jackson is a guy that i
think everybody in america is going to
learn who is
what we do we did against the chiefs
yeah rough fourth quarter he had a rough
fourth quarter yes but look at the
positions he's in he's covering a sami
watkins man-to-man all over the field so
you're gonna get beat at times and he's
still young but that is really gonna be
one of the key match-ups of the game to
me on both sides of the ball are the
corners matching up with the other other
team's receivers man-to-man and i think
like what new england will do like we
heard last year when they beat
jacksonville in the afc championship
they went back to watch training camp
because they had practice against
jacksonville i guarantee they're going
to pull up film of him running routes
against them in practice one-on-ones and
they're going to look at little things
he does at the line of scrimmage that
tells oh when he puts his foot here he
goes this way or when he does this with
his hands he's getting ready to make
this break that will get that in depth
about facing him now but he'll know that
right because he's lived it he will but
will he be able to pick out his little
tells self scout that says exactly south
scout by herself or you'll be in a worm
tunnel
but
that is self scout thyself
[Laughter]
is watching i want them to think i'm
very you know good with the english
language so um i i've continued to think
that the patriots believe that todd
gurley is fine and they're going to get
heavy doses of todd gurley and they're
going to try to take away that running
game and trust
gilmore and jackson to cover woods and
cooks yeah i i think that's the the
thing at least in my assessment and i
know i'm not the grand wizard of
football but i do think to stop the rams
team the first thing you would do is go
hey this is the number what were they
number three or the number five team in
rushing this year i always agree number
three rushing team in football and so
much what they do is off of that run
fake the play actions the boots all of
that i think they're gonna try to crowd
the middle stop the run and they're
gonna say hey stefan gilmore we paid you
to be one of the best corners in
football for a reason and j.c jackson
we're starting you as a rookie because
we think you're awesome and we want to
see you cover woods and cooks all over
the field here's the thing about both of
those guys woods and cooks this is the
reason in my opinion you know you hear
this what will bill take away yeah i
don't think he's going to do it yeah i
don't think he's gonna focus on taking
one person away let's just say he says
all right brandon cooks isn't gonna beat
us
sammy watkins while not being in
pristine health he's always gonna have
that foot issue right sammy watkins and
robert woods could win this game if he
if he treats brandon cooks the way he
treated tyreek hill last week
then one of those two guys could win
this game yes that's why i don't think i
think i'm with you i don't think you
either i think he he plays kind of an
umbrella thing
you know metaphorically i don't think
he's going to focus so much energy or
just play straight man-to-man like yeah
i'm with you i don't think there's
anybody to double because you are you're
going to leave yourself vulnerable in
some other spots here they'll play it
straight up and they like to play
man-to-man anyways and i think they'll
just try to match up straight across the
board we're gonna have a draft when we
return we're gonna look at the best slot
receivers of all time as we scurry to do
our research
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports